Speaker 1: OK. This is just kind of a funny
you kind of like closing the loop on a story.
Many of you who have watched my live streams where
we cover White House press briefings have seen
this reporter in the room from Newsmax. Her name
is Emerald Robinson, and she is. And one of the
most shocking right wing ideologues I've ever
come across. She was recently banned from Twitter
for posting wild anti-vax nonsense, including
about some kind of element called luciferase or
luciferase. You know, Lucifer the devil that she
claims is an ingredient in vaccines. She had a
temporary ban on Twitter. Was let off the ban,
and then within hours, she is now permanently
banned The Daily Beast. So first of all, if you
pull up her account, it's says account suspended.
Twitter suspends accounts which violate the
Twitter rules Newsmax star returns to Twitter and
is permanently banned. Banned hours later for vax
insanity after serving a seven day suspension for
absurdly claiming vaccines contain a Satan linked
tracker. Emerald Robinson doubled down on those
claims and was booted from Twitter. Now again, I
don't like to joke about mental illness. I'm not
joking about this. But the views about a Satan
related element of vaccines or whatever. These
are the types of things where if your family
member was insisting on this, you might say
it might be good to see a psychiatrist. It might
be good to be evaluated for possible delusions,
psychosis, paranoid schizophrenia. It's not a
joke. Newsmax White House correspondent Emerald
Robinson has been permanently suspended from
Twitter for repeatedly violating the social
platforms rules against spread and spreading COVID
misinformation. Twitter initially gave Robinson,
who has relentlessly pushed anti-vax falsehoods
for a year. A temporary timeout after she posted
an insanely absurd claim that the COVID
vaccines contain a glowing tracking device
linked to the devil. She declared
on Twitter quote, Dear Christians,
the vaccines contain a bioluminescent marker
called luciferase so that you can be tracked.
Read the latest book of the New Testament to
see how this ends. She was banned for a week.
While some vaccine research has used the enzyme
luciferase, which has bioluminescent features,
it is not an ingredient of any COVID vaccines on
the market. Further, it doesn't have any satanic
associations, despite deriving its name from the
Latin word Lucifer, which means light bearing.
Besides receiving the reprimand from Twitter,
Robinson was also benched by Newsmax over her
false claims about vaccines prior to taking
Robinson off the air. Newsmax publicly
rebuked its controversial star OK, so cut
to yesterday after serving her week long
Twitter lockout. The conservative firebrand
returned to the social media site with a
fury on Tuesday morning, proclaiming she
was back on Twitter, at least seemingly
showing thread shade at Newsmax for sidelining
her. Robinson then promoted her account on
Substack. A subscription newsletter service
joined me at Substack before I'm banned again.
And then she tweeted one more thing the new COVID
antibody test is called in and it uses luciferase.
No, I'm not kidding. It's not an accident that
they've given this name to this test. It's a
warning. Twitter decided to shut her account
down for good. Permanently suspended for repeated
violations of COVID misinformation policy.
Unclear whether she will be back on the air
at Fox News, at Fox News, at Newsmax again. This,
to me, seems like someone who is really sick,
really sick. It seems almost beyond herself. It's
not even she's doing this as a calculated thing
because it'll reap some kind of financial or other
reward on the end. She's potentially just going to
lose her job, and she's suspended from Twitter.
And it's hard to imagine too many people would
sign up for her Substack. Maybe it's viable. Maybe
it's not. She just seems sick. And unfortunately,
you know, with a lot of these things, as I've said
before, there are unbalanced people and it's just
a matter of what do you come across that you get
fixated with just as easily as she's obsessed with
antibody vaccine Satan, you know this type of
stuff right now. And it seems to be an outlet
for a completely delusional person, disconnected
from reality. It could just as easily be something
else. It could be flat-Earth, could be JFK,
could be water turning frogs, gay, you know,
whatever, right? It just it's it's someone who
is susceptible to this because of something that
they have going on. And it's not a joke to
say in other contexts if you were a parent.
And your 16 year old kid started saying in
serious ways that they have these beliefs.
You might say, let's make an appointment
with a psychiatrist. It's not a joke.
I'm not trivializing mental illness when I say it.
This is someone who looks very, very sick. But for
the good of the broader community, it's the right
decision to ban her from Twitter, that's for sure